foreign
the year 2003
as the Starry Sky was being routinely
observed a small yellow dwarf was
detected in the Phoenix constellation
it was later to be dubbed wasp 96.
the year 2013.
the super wasp orbital telescope
detected an extremely rarefied gas giant
in the immediate vicinity of the star
a preliminary spectral analysis of its
atmosphere revealed that it was
remarkably transparent and practically
devoid of any water vapor
for the year 2022
analysis of the object's atmosphere was
conducted again this time with the help
of the new generation orbital telescope
James Webb which offered an
unprecedented accuracy
scientists were taken aback
if the new data were to be believed the
exoplanet was supposed to be shrouded in
thick layers of clouds
which was the exact opposite of what the
previous observations had revealed
thus the data from the James Webb was in
conflict with the earlier estimates
and the degree of our understanding of
the universe was questioned yet again
so what is this amazing telescope like
and what has it seen in the depths of
space so far
let's take a closer look at it
[Music]
the history of the largest modern
orbital telescope began back in 1996.
its development and modernization took
as long as 25 years after which the
spacecraft left our planet and set out
on its journey through space
it took James Webb a month to reach his
destination Point located one and a half
million kilometers from our planet
because the telescope is equipped with
high Precision infrared sensors it can
see the dimmest and most distant space
objects hidden in the depths of the
universe
however this unmatched sensitivity also
has a downside
the intense radiation from the earth the
moon and the sun interferes with the
faint signals of distant stars and
exoplanets
therefore in order to counteract this
effect the supersensitive instruments
were covered with a multi-layer heat
reflecting screen The Observatory itself
had to be moved away from large
celestial bodies
can be located near the so-called second
LaGrange point in the shadow of our
planet
still the obtained results were
absolutely worth all the effort because
James Webb helped us make quite a number
of Amazing Discoveries pretty much from
the very first days of its operation
with some of them quite expected others
on the other hand prompted additional
questions
one of the studies with a paradoxical
outcome was the spectral analysis of
wasp 96b a glowing exoplanet of
extremely low density
it is located
.045 astronomical units from its parent
star and completes a full orbit around
it in just three and a half days
according to calculations the mass of
the celestial body is half the mass of
Jupiter and its diameter is 20 percent
more than that of Jupiter
to the extreme proximity to the star the
temperature of the object's outer layers
is quite high and reaches
1285 Kelvin or just over a thousand
degrees Celsius
exoplanets of this type fall in the
category of hot Jupiters and are
distinguished by large losses of
atmosphere due to Stellar Wind earlier
measurements showed very clear lines of
sodium in the atmosphere of wasp 96b
which was interpreted by the researchers
as a sign of an unusually clean and
cloudless atmosphere the fact is that
according to the available models of the
structure of gas giants this element can
exist early in the planet's anterior
as we can see traces of it it means that
the upper regions of the celestial
body's atmosphere practically do not
absorb light
it was assumed that thanks to this the
ultra sensitive Detectors of James Webb
could look into the deepest layers of
the exoplanet
however the information obtained by the
telescope turned out to be radically
different
the outer layers of the gas giant
contain great amounts of water vapor
it condenses in the upper atmosphere and
can form a large Haze or thick clouds
reflecting some of the light shed on it
because of this the temperature of the
lower layers of the object May differ
significantly from the calculated values
perhaps the accuracy of the earlier
study was insufficient or else some of
the data was misinterpreted
it is also possible that we do not yet
know of a certain factor that would
allow us to combine the results to form
a single correct picture
wasp 96b remains a mystery which means
it still needs to be studied in more
detail
of course James Webb's discoveries do
not end there
for example 69 light years away there is
an unusual system consisting of three
Brown dwarves at once
these Cosmic bodies are too big to be
planets and at the same time too small
to launch a stable thermonuclear
reaction in their interior
Brown dwarves are usually difficult to
detect as the radiation of their surface
is extremely low but James Webb sees the
universe primarily in infrared which
makes it easy to distinguish objects
that are virtually invisible in the
optical range
the two largest components of the system
are very similar in their
characteristics and are located quite
close to each other
the distance between them is about two
astronomical units and their total mass
is slightly more than 100 times that of
Jupiter
the temperature of both objects is
relatively High reaching 2600 Kelvin
slightly over 2 300 degrees Celsius
the third component to the system is at
a much greater distance about a hundred
astronomical units from the center its
mass is between 14 and 23 Jupiter masses
and its radius is 20 percent more than
that of Jupiter
also this brown dwarf is about twice as
cold as its more massive companions
observations reveal that the temperature
of its outer layers is
1240 Kelvin or slightly below 1000
degrees Celsius
nevertheless the celestial body is
considerably warmer than the gas giants
in our system especially given the
absence of a star that would give it
heat
it was surprising to find that the outer
layers of this brown dwarf contain not
only the usual components such as water
methane or carbon dioxide but also
minute particles of various silicon
compounds
the simplest of these is quads but more
complex substances have also been
detected
these are thought to be concentrated in
the atmosphere of the celestial body in
the form of vast clouds the existence of
such clusters had previously been
predicted from theoretical
considerations because silicon being a
product of Stellar thermonuclear
reactions is quite widespread in the
universe
still until recently observations have
not been able to confirm this hypothesis
it is thought that about 140 million
years ago there was a single gas dust
cloud in the system's place
which later split into three independent
clumps
this event may have been caused by the
gravitational influence of a massive
Celestial body that passed close to the
protostella nebula
remarkably
if the separation had not occurred the
total mass of the formed object would
have been enough to start a
self-sustaining thermonuclear reaction
in this case instead of three browned
wolves we might have been observing a
single tiny star
incidentally the James Webb equipment is
capable of observing not only single
objects tucked away in the depths of
space but tremendous space structures as
well that stretch for hundreds of light
years
one of them is the Karina nebula which
is one of the largest Stellar nurseries
in our galaxy this bright and vast
cluster is located about 8 500 light
years from the earth and has a mass of
up to nine hundred thousand suns
it contains not only giant clouds of
interstellar gas and dust but also
thousands of stars from the smallest
ones to the most gigantic
this is where two of the Milky Way's
brightest objects are located
and wr25
the Luminosity of each is several
million times greater than that of the
Sun
unique objects like that certainly
attract astronomers attention
besides James Webb's infrared cameras
are able to pick out great numbers of
stars in the dusty Haze which were
previously unknown to us
the point is that it is in this area in
space that hundreds of young stars are
constantly getting born
according to Modern Concepts new stars
are formed by gravitational forces that
compress and heat up clouds of cosmic
dust
during its evolutionary process a
protostar goes through several stages
until finally a thermonuclear reaction
kicks in in its interior this theory has
been confirmed by multiple observations
but many details of this long and
complex process currently remain
understudied
the formation of a new star sometimes
takes millions of years but astronomers
don't need that long to observe it
thanks to James Webb's infrared senses
thousands of protostars and young stars
at various stages of evolution have been
detected in the Carina nebula
it is important to note that all these
objects formed within the same gas cloud
which means that they're very similar in
terms of composition and age
by observing them researchers can fully
trace the process of star formation
and better understand what forces are
involved
some phases of this process predicted
only in theory take hours or days and
with James Webb the chance of capturing
them is greatly enhanced
for all we know we may soon be able to
admire a photo of a young star flaring
up thousands of light years from the Sun
meanwhile an 18 section mirror six and a
half meters in diameter and an on-board
array of high accuracy instruments allow
James Webb to capture light from objects
much further away at the very edge of
the visible universe
there are more than 13 billion years old
giving us a glimpse of the earliest
times immediately after the hypothetical
Big Bang
however even James Webb would not have
been able to see their luminescence but
for one unique coincidence
the phenomenon of gravitational lensing
has long been known to scientists
this physical phenomenon helps us to
better see into the depths of the
universe
and this is how it works
a powerful gravity generated by a
massive body focuses and amplifies light
from a source behind it
such an effect can be produced early on
condition that a great many factors
happily combine so it is not surprising
that it is one of the rarest phenomena
in the universe it is all the more
surprising that while observing the
Galaxy cluster's Max 0723 located about
4 billion light years from the earth
James Webb captured light of a space
object passing through gravitational
lenses as many as three times
in total the radiation was Amplified
about 20 times without which astronomers
would hardly have been able to
distinguish it from background noise
the object is thought to be a distant
and very old Galaxy whose age is
estimated to be 13 billion years
about 10 other star clusters have also
been detected
a thought to have originated between 200
and 700 million years after the Genesis
of the universe
According to some observations they have
a complex structure which takes tens of
millions of years to form
this discovery will allow scientists to
develop the existing ideas about the
early stages of the universe's Evolution
and may even prompt to question its age
unfortunately we're still know very
little about such remote times and James
Webb will surely help us learn more
about them
the state-of-the-art telescope has
pushed the boundaries of our cognition
to the very edge of the universe
there are likely to be dozens of
discoveries hidden in its images right
now waiting to be soon interpreted
meanwhile the James Webb Mission has
only just begun and there are years of
operation up ahead
we will be following its progress and
hope for your support in this long
complex and really exciting Endeavor
after all the universe is getting a
little closer every day and let's keep
in touch
foreign